[Music]
on this friday night omicron
overwhelming understaffed hospitals
fresh please to the unvaccinated
healthcare workers will express
frustration the talk of making vaccines
mandatory plus the complications and
consequences of cancelling in-person
classes we are seeing a drastic increase
in self-harm behaviors and indigenous
communities covet outbreak and cry for
help we're remote
and we're first nation
people don't give a damn
prison punishments the three white men
who murdered ahmed arbury are sentenced
plus the defiant one but if you want it
to be right here right now that's okay
with me
a groundbreaker of stage and screen dies
at 94.
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a look at what's happening
in canadian hospitals they are filling
up with people who have covered 19
because the omicron variant is spreading
faster than any other version of the
virus ontario is the latest province to
have more people in hospital with coven
now than at any other time during the
pandemic almost 2 500 people are now
hospitalized with covet in ontario a
record high the majority are
unvaccinated and today the federal
health minister had this message
rapid tests are not going to end the
crisis rapid tests are not going to
solve kovin 19.
the only thing that will solve kobe 19
is vaccination
many hospitals operated at maximum
capacity before the pandemic now even
though they've postponed non-urgent
surgeries and procedures to help free up
capacity they're concerned about what's
coming eric sorenson has our top story
tonight
there's no hiding no sugar coating the
data the omicron variant surge is a
crisis getting worse by the day covet
case counts in canada have spiked 400
percent higher than the peak of the
third wave a seven day average of forty
two thousand cases daily and that is an
undercount of the real numbers which are
simply going through the roof now covet
hospitalizations are also going up not
as high as in previous waves yet but now
above 3600 and rising sharply
it's true many cases aren't as serious
but the numbers in intensive care are
also climbing these trends are all
increasing as a result of the sheer
number of cases occurring with this
rapidly spreading variant in canadian
hospitals a perfect and terrible storm
is brewing more health care workers are
off sick at a time when more coveted
patients are flooding in the number of
people who are getting sick is going up
and it's putting increasing demands on a
healthcare system where the amount of
personnel is limited because they
themselves are getting coveted ontario
and quebec are seeing the biggest jump
in hospitalizations but all provincial
health systems will be under strain at
the same time it's not clear the
canadian health care system can handle
what's coming and ottawa is warning the
provinces that it has only limited
health to offer it shouldn't surprise
anybody that
it's not a limitless
number of federal health care resources
that we can bring to bear it is striking
and frustrating for many that the
majority of hospitalizations come from
the small percentage of canadians who
are
unvaccinated just this morning on my
shift i've admitted three people with
very severe illness with covid all of
whom were unvaccinated i think
healthcare workers will express
frustration because those are the people
that will
have more severe illness today the
federal health minister kicked off what
he believes is coming a discussion with
the provinces about making vaccines
mandatory what will
make us move through this crisis and end
it is vaccination testing masking
distancing all remain important but says
duclos to end the pandemic expect
mandatory vaccines to be taken up in the
weeks ahead and that will bring some
controversy eric sorensen global news
toronto
and here's a measure of how any
conversation with the provinces about
making vaccines mandatory might go
premier jason kenney tweeted today
alberta's legislature removed the power
of mandatory vaccination from the public
health act last year and will not
revisit that decision period the
brunswick's health minister said there
isn't any place in canada looking at
mandates
it is a serious issue
but we maintain right now
that education
pushing for those to get vaccinated
showing
the differences that it that the vaccine
makes as dr russell did today
that will be the path we'll stay on for
the near future
parents with school-age kids are back
into the cycle of trying to figure out
what to do with their children in places
where online learning is back such as
ontario the juggling and the stress is
underway again tonight abigail beeman
looks specifically at healthcare workers
who are scaling back their hours so they
can look after their kids
if you know you know familiar scenes of
virtual learning it is chaotic in order
to manage online learning for his two
children ottawa pediatrician dr anja
rakhowsky scaled back appointments by up
to 40 percent stopped staffing a kids
covet assessment center and most
impactful he says stopped working at a
kid's vaccine clinic it seems that the
government in ontario is making the
return to school somewhat conditional on
the vaccination rates of these children
well if we cannot staff vaccine centers
either nurses or physicians because we
have to stay home and take care of our
children
the speed at which we will achieve that
vaccination goal in this age group will
just be slower yeah about 20 rejection
child psychologist and mom tess clifford
is also scaling back hours she's part of
a group behind back to school ontario
dot ca in its first two days about 23
000 people used it to send 180 000
emails to ontario decision makers
calling to get kids back in class we
know that the mental health and academic
and just general well-being impacts for
kids have been huge with each school
closure now managing three of her own
kids at home adrian matheson has since
the pandemic began had to triple staff
at this ottawa family psychology
practice and the need is only becoming
more dire she just closed her wait list
after it reached 70 people the length of
time that they're waiting we just don't
feel as appropriate or safe her practice
is seeing an uptick in all kinds of
mental health and academic challenges we
are seeing a drastic increase in
self-harm behaviors particularly for our
young adolescents and our adolescents
she's even more worried about long-term
effects we may not see for years we want
to get the kids back in school but we
have to make sure when the kids back in
school they can function ontario's
premier again cited teacher absenteeism
as a challenge his office did not
directly respond to questions about the
impact of health care absenteeism there
is emergency child care coming but not
until next week and not accessible to
all there have been no clear metrics for
a return to class january 17th
professionals tell us they're hearing
about hopelessness and mistrust not just
from parents but from kids
donna
abigail beeman in ottawa thank you in
ontario a remote first nation
overwhelmed with people who have tested
positive for covid has asked for urgent
assistance from the military and it's
now waiting bearskin lake reserve is in
ontario's far north nearly half its 400
residents have tested positive for the
virus the majority of the residents are
fully vaccinated and a booster campaign
is underway but omicron is spreading
fast and so many people are now
self-isolating there aren't enough to
deliver the basic needs to the community
david aiken reports i'm here in bearskin
lake
as i'm driving around it's it's like a
ghost town a ghost town created by covet
19. nearly half of the 400 or so
residents here have the virus the chief
of bearskin lake himself is in
self-isolation with his family i was on
the front lines for a first few days but
i had to isolate due to my son being
positive
so i've been in isolation since monday
so
i'm exhausted at this moment the chief
says about 80 percent here are
vaccinated that's a rate is good or
better than most provinces and a
pediatric vaccine program got underway
just before christmas for myself i had
my two doses and
booster but even still covet infections
are everywhere an eight-month-old infant
among the most recent to get it almost
everyone is self-isolating in their
homes homes heated by wood stoves that
need a constant supply of fuel in minus
30 degree temperatures some volunteers
from outside the community have flown in
to help but they're exhausted my name is
uh stuart cam nordman and i'm a member
of this first nation this is a very
scary situation everybody that we meet
we do see their concerns and after we
are gone who is going to take over the
chief and council asked the army to take
over that plea for help was made monday
i would like to see something happening
for my community because
i don't think i don't know if we can
last any longer but the community is
still waiting for an answer because
we're removed
and we're remote
and we're first nation
people don't give a damn ottawa has been
in daily contact with bearskin lake
leaders and has provided just over a
million dollars to help cover the cost
of plane charters and supplies for this
remote community i understand the
anxiety that people are feeling and
frustration because it's the frustrating
situation i mean people are used to
being able to take care of themselves
and and i think you know having to uh to
rely on others to meet basic needs can
be
frightening and frustrating plans to fly
in the army are still under review
david aiken global news ottawa
in the u.s there are more known cases of
covid19 now than at any time during the
pandemic more than 700 000 today alone
hospitals are dealing with a surge in
cases and other businesses are trying to
cope with having so many employees off
sick as jackson proskow reports there
are growing calls for the white house to
come up with a new covid strategy
american hospitals face a double threat
more coveted patients than ever
including children and more doctors and
nurses off sick with the virus as the
hospitals get strained
there is less opportunity to
to provide
all these resources to the one single
patient
the incredible surge in covet cases
averaging more than six hundred thousand
per day is also taking a toll on
everyday life
public transit systems have slashed
service with drivers unavailable
airlines continue to cancel thousands of
flights due to staffing shortages
there's even a shortage of lab workers
to process coveted tests the next few
weeks and possibly even into the month
of february are going to be pretty
dismal because we are projecting surges
in other parts of the country that will
peak in the next two to four weeks in an
op-ed in the journal of the american
medical association several former
advisors to president joe biden called
for a new strategy writing covet 19 is
here to stay policy makers need to
specify the goals and strategies for the
new normal of life i don't think covert
is here to stay biden has so far
resisted calls for any drastic shift in
approach rejecting measures like vaccine
mandates for air travel we're going to
be able to control this the new normal
is not going to be what it is now it's
going to be better how the u.s gets to
that better place remains uncertain
omicron's extraordinary spread has not
changed the fundamental problems with
the u.s response
vaccination and booster campaigns are
still lagging and forecast suggests the
u.s death toll could top 1 million by
march
jackson prosko global news washington
in the u.s employment rose less than
expected in december because of a
shortage of workers the unemployment
rate fell sharply in december to a
pandemic low employers added 199 000
jobs last month the fewest in 2021 wages
went up 4.7 percent assigned companies
are keen on hiring as a record number of
people have quit
canada also had the lowest unemployment
rate in december since just before the
start of the pandemic 55 000 new jobs
were added but statistics canada says
the 5.9 percent unemployment rate was
recorded before public health
restrictions ramped up since then many
businesses have had to close or scale
back operations
in the u.s state of georgia three white
men found guilty of murdering ahmed
arbury an unarmed black man have been
sentenced to life in prison gregory and
travis mcmichael a father and son who
never showed any remorse were denied any
chance of parole they chased cornered
and shot the 25 year old who was out for
a jog in a mostly white neighborhood
william bryan a neighbor who recorded
video of arbory's last moments was
granted a chance at parole after serving
30 years arbory's mother had asked the
judge for life sentences
but i knew
that we would come out with a victory
yes
i never doubted it
and i knew that today would come
during the sentencing hearing the judge
spoke about the terror artery faced
while being hunted by the men who chased
him in pickup trucks he said he imposed
severe sentences in part because of
their callous words and actions captured
on video
a fierce winter storm smacks atlantic
canada coming up the warning to bundle
up and hunker down
[Music]
big parts of this country are under an
extreme cold warning right now atlantic
canada is also bracing for blizzard
conditions global news chief
meteorologist anthony farnell is here
with the details anthony
well donna this storm is still
intensifying it picked up a lot of
moisture from the warm waters of the
gulf stream and it's depositing that in
the form of incredibly heavy snowfall as
we zoom in i want to show you this band
that's extending across the bay of fundy
into new brunswick and into pei as well
these are blizzard conditions for the
next several hours snowfall rates of 5
to 10 centimeters every hour as well
we've had lightning and thunder snow in
halifax another 15 to 25 centimeters for
much of pei and then all of this moves
into newfoundland with 30 to 50
centimeters expected there as well the
winds have been gusting over 80 and that
is piling up a lot of water along with
unusually high tides king tides they
call them and that means flooding storm
surge warnings extending through a large
area of atlantic canada as well out west
it's been the snow it's been the
freezing rain in bc that system will
bring some snow into the prairies but
it's also going to bring milder
temperatures the wind chill still brutal
and so much of the prairies there's some
relief in sight in fact by early next
week some locations will be back above
freezing
donna
well that would be a relief anthony
farnell thanks
[Music]
shoot to kill ahead the order to use
deadly force to stop the protests in
kazakhstan
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
after days of unrest kazakhstan's
authoritarian leader says he has now
given orders to shoot to kill without
warning it's a major escalation and a
crackdown on anti-government protests
the situation is calmer now but troops
from russia and other countries are
still arriving in kazakhstan at the
invitation of the president redmond
shannon reports
with security forces now well in control
a much quieter day in almaty friday only
some reports of gunfire
this woman says she is scared and her
heart hurts knowing young people are
dying authorities say security forces
have killed at least 26 people referring
to them as armed criminals
state tv is telling people to remain
indoors if there is violence in their
area
president
jean-marc tokyo went a step further
warning kazakhs that police and soldiers
will shoot to kill without warning he
says he will not negotiate with what he
says is a coordinated group of bandits
and terrorists he gave no evidence to
support his claims they are foreign
trained president
vladimir putin
reserved a special thank you for his
russian counterpart vladimir putin
more russian troops arrived friday
forming the largest part of an
international peacekeeping force invited
to kazakhstan by tokyov
self-described kazakh opposition leader
in exile mukhtar ablazov is calling it a
russian occupation russia has a military
presence in eight of the 14 states that
gained independence from the former
soviet union three decades ago including
ukraine's crimea peninsula which it
annexed in 2014. the russian-dominated
collective security treaty organization
says its mission in kazakhstan is
temporary but the u.s secretary of state
expressed concerns about the
intervention it's not clear
why they feel the need for any outside
assistance so we're trying to learn more
about it once
russians are in your house it's
sometimes very difficult to get them to
leave
some kha'zix around the world are
voicing similar worries
meanwhile new video has emerged of the
toppling of a statue of former dictator
nur sultan nazarbayev he is an ally of
tokyo but has not been seen since the
unrest began redmond shannon global news
london
from groundbreaking roles to his
singular talent how sydney cuache
changed hollywood
if you were to measure the achievements
of sidney poitier by just one year
1967 it would still be legendary he
starred in three movies that year all of
them became classics he was the first
african-american actor to win an academy
award and news of his death at age 94
has led to a flood of tributes from
people who adored him and were inspired
by him here's mike armstrong
dr what
what would you have done it wasn't so
much a career in a changing hollywood as
a career that changed hollywood where is
it when sidney poitier started acting
there were no leading roles for
african-american men by the time he
retired there were no limits
i came here at a time
when this hollywood did you know was not
the hollywood here when i arrived
my father was a tomato farmer sidney
poitier was born in 1927 in florida but
raised in the bahamas when he moved back
to the u.s the age of 15 he'd had only
one year of schooling he could barely
read he was a dishwasher in new york
city with three dollars to his name when
he was looking for a better dishwashing
job in the juanats on the opposite page
was an ad for an african-american
theater it said actors wanted
hey i figured i've tried one
might as well give the other a go
from the stage he moved to the screen
his first oscar nomination was in 1958
for the defiant ones
his oscar win was five years later for
lilies of the field why'd you go and do
that they call me mr tibbs he would go
on to reshape how african americans were
seen on screen he wasn't a character who
accepted being slapped
he slapped back what's he was selective
in his roles in the heat of the night he
was a detective
to sir with love a teacher mom and guess
who's coming to dinner this is john a
doctor there just as i thought with each
role there was a grace and dignity that
includes when his civil rights work off
screen overshadowed his work on it i am
an awful lot of things so i wish you
would uh
pay me the respect
do
sidney poitier would work well into his
70s he was knighted awarded a lifetime
honor by the motion picture academy and
a medal of freedom by president obama
he was also beloved in his industry i
never
met another person
who affected
protected
an entire race
i bow before your spirit
sir sidney poitier was 94.
and that is global national for this
friday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is this wintry scene in oakville
ontario we'd love to see your canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]